gardez pense à moi regarder dans son
hangar 50 ans d'histoire du cirque est
tout autant de trésors
pourtant la moitié environ de brad est
détruit faute de place dans un nouvel
entrepôt gilbert edelstein le pdg du
cirque pinder est propriétaire du lieu
veut vider le bâtiment vétuste pour le
détruire
suite à des alertes de la mairie la
patriarche reconnaît avoir laissé
pourrir la situation mais il est trop
tard pour sauver tout le patrimoine
indiscutablement le plafond et part
faire quelque chose dont j'ai pas
d'autre endroit où les mettre si je les
remets à notre endroit je vais de nous
avoir des problèmes avec les autres
mairies on n'aura pas le temps de tout
rénover parce que ça coûte très cher
actuellement le cirque fait pas un
métier facile
donc on l'a pas trop d'argent à mettre
pour la rénovation dans ce choix
cornélien souvent les souvenirs et
l'affect l'emportent avec cette voiture
là est bien le vrai qu'une petite moi je
les connais ils étaient ici ça a été un
des premiers qui m'a grimés en clowns en
faisait le coup quand j'avais l'âge de
mon fils à 14 ans une grille mais ici
dans cette remorque et il y avait le
petit n'a l'autre petit nain le kun
enrico qui dormaient lui si il avait sa
chambre ici d'ailleurs regardez et
encore des preuves des souvenirs c'était
dans la caravane des clous d'un autre
clou de la collection ce derner datant
des années 60 a appartenu à charles
spiesser dresseur de fauves et deuxième
propriétaire du pinder ou alors se
marrent bon camion des gi's utilisé
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale est
converti en utilitaires de cirque à
patrimoine inestimable pour le fils
tous ces diamants de siècle parce que
quand on voit des vieux gm ces cantons
vieux des voeux des vieux marmont des
vieux bernard et des vieux véhicules
comme ça qu'on eu une histoire avec le
cirque convoyage et de partout dans la
france qui brillait aux yeux du public
un petit peu de partout sur toutes les
places en france eh ben c'est un petit
peu normal qu'on les retape pour en
faire quelque chose impossible de savoir
pour l'heure combien seront restaurés
puis présenté au musée du cirque pinder
ni combien finiront à la casse faute de
repreneur quant aux 35 mille mètres
carrés de terrain gilbert edelstein joue
son va tout avec la mairie de monnaie
soit l aide est installé une partie de
son parc d'attractions pindar landes où
il devant et quitte la commune